The credits have rolled and
the reviews are in — but is
Indy's final adventure whip-cracking
fun… or does it belong in a museum?
Indiana Jones and the Dial of Destiny has got
a lot riding on it. It's the first film in the
Indiana Jones franchise since Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull, which notoriously received a
frosty reception from fans when it came out
in 2008. Dial of Destiny is also unique in
that it's the first film in the franchise to
be neither directed by Steven Spielberg nor
have a story by George Lucas. Top all of that
with a reported $300 million budget, and it's
clear that the pressure is high for Disney's
first — and maybe only — Indiana Jones project.
Of course, a significant number of fans will
be happy just to see Harrison Ford suit up
as Indy one last time, but nostalgia only goes
so far. The film has a June 30th release date
in the United States, but, as it premiered at
the Cannes Film Festival, reviews have already
begun trickling in. So what do critics have
to say so far about Indy's final adventure?
It's probably worth considering Dial of Destiny in
the context of the franchise's impressive legacy.
"It's not the years, honey. It's the mileage."
Raiders of the Lost Ark is widely considered
one of the best adventure films of all time,
and people have plenty of love for
Temple of Doom and The Last Crusade, too.
"Those people are trying to kill us!"
"I know, Dad!" "
This is a new experience for me."
"Happens to me all the time."
While it's hard to say whether Dial of Destiny
will reach those heights, it certainly appears as
though critics think the movie is a step up from
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull. More importantly,
many critics found it to be a fitting
conclusion to the Indiana Jones film saga.
Fans can rest easy knowing the fifth installment
of the Indiana Jones franchise offers a fun,
old-fashioned romp. GamesRadar+'s critic enjoyed
the throwback vibe of the movie, writing:
"There's a nostalgic, old-fashioned feel
to the film, a rollicking, globe-trotting
ride that pits Ford's intrepid adventurer
against the Nazis once more. Certainly,
it makes up for 2008's outlandish Kingdom of
the Crystal Skull, with a more grounded story."
The final verdict from the outlet is
four out of five stars, with the summary:
"A terrific thrill ride. With Ford in fine form,
Indy's last stand is a highly satisfying
blend of action, humour and emotion."
Others agree the film is a lot of fun,
with one mild criticism being that it
plays it too safe. The Radio Times says:
"Perhaps the film could've been more daring
– it feels fairly safe – but fans will leave
cinemas feeling like their old hero
had one final great outing in him."
While much of the focus is
naturally on Harrison Ford,
the movie boasts a talented supporting
cast, including Phoebe Waller-Bridge.
And it sounds like she's more than a match
for Indy himself. As The Guardian notes:
"Phoebe Waller-Bridge has a tremendous co-star
turn as Indy's roguish goddaughter Helena Shaw,
who wears shorts and shirt making her look
like a grownup, naughty Enid Blyton heroine."
Meanwhile, the Radio Times praises how
the film grapples with an aging
protagonist. The review reads:
"At its heart is a great performance from Ford,
one of his most emotional outings as Indy,
as he comes to terms with his
ageing body and life-regrets."
GamesRadar+ also notes how Indy's struggles with
his age and regrets grounds
the movie. The review says:
"We see the character has grown older, but not
necessarily wiser. Drinking a bit too much,
he's full of regrets about pursuing fortune
and glory and leaving his loved ones behind."
Not every critic has been so enamored with
the movie, however. Donald Clarke of The
Irish Times was a bit more critical, giving the
film three out of five stars and concluding that:
"Nobody with a brain in their heads will compare
Dial of Destiny favourably
to the first three films."
But even if it's no Raiders of the Lost Ark,
it sounds like Dial of Destiny will see Indiana
Jones go out swinging. At this point, even a solid
Indy adventure might be all anyone can hope for.